welcome maurice we haven't had you here
in the studio for a while youtube asks
every single broadcast where is maurice
and well maybe you can shed some light
yeah sometimes i get lost as to where i
am too because i'm traveling so much uh
having a good time as you know i took a
year off from commentary everybody asked
me do you want to do commentary you and
say no because i just needed this year
to recharge refresh do some writing uh
do a chessable course that's out now as
well so just sort of like a sabbatical
if you will but like i come back the
first day i come back and there's
craziness here in st louis so it feels
like i never left tell us what happened
it seems that you got here to st louis
and magnus said uh-uh and left
well you know magnus and i have had
run-ins in the past so
but i'm not taking blame for this one it
looks like it looks like hans is doing
more than enough by himself we
definitely had a lot of drama you've
been calling a lot of sync fields but
this one this one feels very unique you
go back you try to remember any sing
phil cup of course the first one when
magnus declined the draw against lavonne
and that big one that he won of course
fabi winning seven in a row that was
interesting a little bit of a comeback
story with wesley being last one year
winning the next year but absolutely oh
and dig loren also the the the one he
defeated bangla that was pretty dramatic
beating magnus in a tie break when
magnus hadn't lost one in like 10 years
all that was cool
nothing matches this like not even close
uh maybe fabi700 i would say would be
the one but this is just this is
must-see tv you gotta get your popcorn
now and just start popping oh man it's
been great the internet has just been
buzzing about this tournament everybody
with their own speculations what do you
think is going on
i got no idea i mean i got no i really
have no intel here i think that uh
it's clear something's up with hans and
magnus you know something's there uh the
way
hans has spoken about him uh that last
quote was was vintage i'm glad i beat
him before he left i mean that's that's
gonna last forever i'm curious to know
magnus's reaction to that as well we
know there's some history with hans in
the past with some some issues that that
are pretty well documented about him
possibly cheating and and so and and him
taking punishment for that as well will
will he admit to that will that come out
as a statement or or what i don't know
but i think that uh it's frothy whatever
it is it's like real housewives of
st louis
maybe some real house husbands or
whatever but it's it's incredible what's
going on it has absolutely been
fantastic but tell us about your year
tell us about some of the projects that
you've been involved in maurice i know
that everybody misses you so why are
they missing you what have you been
doing instead well like i said i did a
chessable course
my first ever yasser has done like seven
or eight so he's a vet but i did one
called the secrets of chess geometry it
just came out uh just in late august
it's blowing up i'm totally thrilled
with it it's just ideas that i've
collected over the last 20 years and
decided to now finally start publishing
when i was doing real work like you are
it was just too much there was not
enough time to get projects done so
that's what i'm really proud of and as i
said it's out now i'm actually also
writing a children's book
and uh my publisher
is doing it's actually illustrated for
five to seven year olds i'm not doing
the illustration i'm not that talented
but i did tell the story it's about my
life uh little pieces of my life so
that'll be coming out sometime next year
i'm doing other another book as well on
chess as it relates to business i've
been doing a lot of corporate speaking
uh google amazon pinterest century 21
ibm
some
no-name companies and uh that's been
amazing as well so i've been keeping
busy no certainly it seems that you have
your hands a full uh tell us for the
fans when are you coming back
you know i don't know the answer to that
question so i can't tell the fans that i
promised myself that i will not answer
that question until january 1st 2023 i
won't even inspect the question until
january 1st 2023 so until then i'll keep
doing what i'm doing
try to do a couple more chestable
courses
hopefully finish this book that's been
taking a while to write the one
interesting business and uh and see what
else comes up i mean there's some other
cool tv projects that i can't speak on
right now but some hollywood stuff
people think i've moved to california
and i haven't but because i've been out
there and i've been meeting some some
pretty cool stars like you know jamie
foxx for one and we'll see if that pans
out but it's it's just been an
interesting time doesn't seem like your
life is terrible right now it's not bad
it's not bad no complaints i still miss
you guys though no question about that
no we miss you here as well yasser jump
in here in the conversation i mean
you've been working with maurice for how
long oh my gosh yes and i go back to the
mid 90s somewhere
uh yeah we've known each other a while
because kasparov and on for one i was
always in 95. but i thought it was
pretty cool maurice that you were the
tourist in madrid i'd still like to get
some more
insights of what you found
about the candidates tournament that you
liked and uh it was it was history
yeah it was fun being in the candidates
you know what in general it's been fun
being a chess fan i always talked about
myself as a super fan i actually got a
job where i get to watch the best
players in the world duke it out i had a
front row seat and to be a fan uh like a
true fan not working at all not worrying
about being stuck in the studio sorry
guys but being able to just roam around
meet people hang out talk leave when you
want come back when you want it's just
been it's been fun i'm like a true fan
of the game now and i sit at home a lot
creating chess puzzles one of my big
hobbies now you know i try to torture
i've sent you a few puzzles alejandro uh
you know just to torture the strong
players with this side of myself and i
never thought this would be a sign i'm
like spending three or four hours a day
creating chest puzzles and i'm going to
tell you guys for those that are not
familiar these puzzles are hard
they're hard i'm aware
we set them up for the us olympic team
and they spent an hour trying to solve
one of them it was favi it was live on
all of the girls were there trying to
solve it it was hard guys eventually got
it but it took some time that warms my
heart a hundred percent that's what you
want to hear i love making really strong
players suffer over my puzzles i did it
with mvl i did with alireza called my
puzzle over 27.50 for sure so that you
know i can't play like these guys so
it's great to make them suffer over the
puzzle creations so that's been a real
joy for me and that's the side that's
just been coming out over this last
period of time that creative side that
shows that i'm still passionate about
chess i may not be playing i may not be
doing commentary but i'm always going to
be part of this game oh i have to agree
completely that sometimes it's nice to
look at chess from a different
perspective as we have a result mvl has
drawn against nepal we didn't see a lot
of that end game but nepo seems to have
shown exactly how to defend it we'll go
over that in a second but as i was
saying sometimes looking at chess from a
different perspective is really fun
people have asked me do you prefer
coaching or do you prefer playing at the
olympia now my answer is always i prefer
going as a tourist it is definitely the
most fun tournament to follow being in
the midst of it so i am totally jealous
you are over there in madrid maurice
well i'm glad you're in st louis how
long are you staying only uh just today
is another full day and then i'm off to
dallas to do a corporate talk so it's
just just to be around everybody the
gang see joy bray and rex and tony and
everybody it's been great and i'm and
i'm here just at this point in time
which is excellent that i showed up on
the right day and when i leave trust me
i'll be following you guys well you
certainly know how to pick them thank
you maurice for joining us here in the
studio we'll update some of the games
guys back to you hold on hold on maurice
uh do a last question the columbo last
question the youths man tell tell me
your reaction to the youths ali raza
what he did in the st louis rapid
bullets was amazing and hans niemann is
amazing they're 19 years old uh maurice
yeah ad goukish uh eric geisse all the
indian kids
it's what's happening right now is
incredible i think chess is seeing the
generations start one rise another
realize that they're coming they're
coming it's like a wave a tidal wave of
young players and that's what we want to
see the change of the generation
we've seen it happen time and time again
we've seen when when magnus made his
rise fabi made his rise and the ones we
thought were entrenched at the top had
to seed ground as well so that's exactly
what's happening in the next five years
the chess are going to be absolutely
amazing and it's a great time to be a
fan absolutely i agree this is
a change of the guard
the changing of the generations maurice
always good to see you wonderful and
good luck
with your chestable courses that they're
out
now the the one has already been
released and as marie's saying is
working on others so uh get yours while
they're hot thank you again maurice
thanks guys always fantastic to to see
more race i was that was absolutely my
highlight of the day yesterday
yeah
while everything else was going on
suddenly the door opens and maurice
waltz is in and
it just yeah warms the cockles of my
heart to see him every time and
let's just one of the most positive
people i know absolutely